[Music]
if you've ever so much even said a nice
thing to a woman simply that's right
you're a simp if you ever said where my
hug get simp
I got bad news for you simp I would spit
but I can't be bothered if you start
shaking just by the thought of a girl
being criticized I got bad news for you
your simple and nothing else it goes
like this
SOI boy cut simp you're the lowest of
the low
I'm sorry I don't make the rules girls
are stinky poos yeah this is how it's
been for millennia eons but now all the
sudden this guy has to come along and
ruin it for everyone I don't think girls
are stinky poos can we have sex now
that's you sympathetic don't ever ever
say nice to female before we used to
respect women
now I don't even know imagine donating
to a negro pathetic this is what costs
this outrage of simply it's all the e
girl's fault remember I don't know a few
months ago there was this girl that was
complaining about not getting a $5
donation or to provide for the content
that you're watching because it's like
people just she knows what she's doing
notice what now to say she does that
she's antagonizing the Cinch she's
basically riling up all the her simps
with this hand gesture for the content
that you're watching because it's like
people just really have no they really
don't respect me as a content creator
well of course they don't
why the [ __ ] would they and then the
sims come to to the restaurant she's an
attractive woman who didn't act like a
nice person did she see it just what it
makes fresh sexually frustrated in cells
angry you notice the lack of eye contact
the lack of confidence the slapped cheek
posture that's all hit all three simpler
there
I'm getting your attention feel like I
touched like vampire touching holy water
this makes me sick
this man is beyond any any save I don't
know English but this sim problem has
gone way in up and beyond getting a
pedicure for my best guy friend ever
now if only I can find a boyfriend like
this simps a bit simpler you better pack
your bag and move to Sim City right now
cuz that's where you're still spending
the rest of day the one that listened to
me all right that's fine take it from
xxx dentists yawn huh he tried to warn
us he tried to warn us goddammit
that you wouldn't listen about the simps
do you know the difference between a man
and a simp is it looks is it coochie no
a man she was just simple BAE it's that
simple
I like the eye funny tag hair simp
listen if I 96 Bugatti calls you a simp
then you might just want to reconsider
your life choices
alright that's all I'm gonna say I'm not
gonna call anyone a simpie even though
you are a simp my boy sent me this one
thousand seven hundred people really
really in here watching that's ticks
snow like in the 1700 samp's you'd think
I'm Homer the way I Simpson stop it me a
simp pays $49 per month for only fans
only fans the ten thousands of terabytes
of free porn on the internet be like you
know old jokes aside it's kind of sad
now that you're not allowed to
compliment women online and when they're
already always under constant boorish
and bullying on the internet' now people
aren't allowed to be nice to women it's
kind of [ __ ] up that's what a simple
say pathetic n-word will call you a simp
for treating women right but praise thee
for treating women bad URL weird for
treating women right the does that mean
betta
pathetic yeah look at this take anyone
pointing and yeah they're safe if you
have these hair I got bad news for you
this
haircut curly top with overhang big
Simpson big Simpson ignore that I funny
tags alright guys come on please you
have to understand even the calculators
make it fun of you if your calculator is
calling yourself then you might want to
reconsider life choice
so Barack Obama women are indisputably
web better than men simp imagine voting
for a simple cringe him guy named
himself said that's how you know it's
gone too far if people just willingly
call themselves Simpa hey Nicholas yes
babe I think I'm ready you know to have
sex I figured you'd say that so I came
prepared
you brought a condom no silly
[Music]
Nik kind of kinky I weighed this room
with explosives
good sex is a sin have fun running in
hell Beth premarital sex that's a big
[ __ ] hikes that's how you fight it
you blow them up with explosives now I
would never incite violence against
women but if they want premarital sex
you know what the joke is I'm not saying
it so therefore I don't get in trouble
major I located the SIP commencing
operation bra moment data get that sim
[Music]
Russell Russell
[Music]
why would you do that Russell why would
you sink so low my understand things are
tough I understand life is hard but
never never do that again
imagine being top donor - Annie girl my
tips are lucky if someone even looks at
them r.i.p oh no oh no oh no oh no stop
it
show me I look at them ah today's your
tits lucky day I'll look at them stop it
stop it stop it said cringe if you ever
see a guy carrying flowers around big
simp flowers balloons someone else's
boyfriend's laundry that's a big sign
that it's simply oh wow look at that
it's international simply add inria lies
well there you go
there you have it that's must be why
there's this sudden outbreak that's the
only reason I can think of at least use
this for any simply come across online
gosh as much as I I like to send me you
know it's just gonna be everywhere all
all the 12 year olds going without
really understanding the full context of
what it means and how really important
this meme is cuz previously these boys
we didn't have a word for them these
Sims that cause it calls out in cells in
cell as out
I call them in cell can we [ __ ] now
please can I touch you now please I keep
my pent can you change diaper now please
I'm gonna crush another simple good
ignore the AI funny alright it's
important look at this this is a lot
about society good sila is dripping in
sauce while Kong is being a food you can
sip and discuss then now come on dude
play fortnight I
and bro I said it's fine don't worry
about her she's asleep in my arms man I
don't want to wake her she's so cute
unfriend anyone right now that's ever
done this she liked and we published my
meme bro she clearly likes me she's
clearly into me she wants to [ __ ] sip
here it is
12-year olds who don't know what a same
page when they see any guy talking to a
girl it's true if you ever said you look
nice today simp shut the [ __ ] up simp
stop being nice stop it this ends now
it's me it's me I'm the guy who asked
it's me they love this they think
they're so special no one ever asked who
I am but I care I care how are you know
you don't set when your friend says he
has to go to the stairwell with a girl
to work on a project for school
endless sim it never ends but it ends
now simp I'm telling you all the simply
is that watching this right now break
free start lifting immediately punch
something I wouldn't say punch you know
what I mean but I am also saying that
you should do that
that's him that's him right there
officer that's the guy who learned the
word symplast week not me I've been at
get their way
same OD see how far this is gone there's
no a simple mo t like this wasn't enough
how nice guys think sex worse simp
not tricking more D not rich from
wreaking more they know he can't be a
simp man God everyone knows the easiest
way to get mad push is to be mean to
women Ricky from Rick and Morty everyone
knows this the simp constantly throws
other men under the bus
check I mean not me always there to
comfort your girlfriend when y'all argue
who would do anything for women always
agree with whatever women say I've never
disagreed with a woman that's me I met
it would never happen abnormally
persistent super thirsty does anything
for some PP women are always
I you know why because it's true I'm
tired of standing here today and
pretending like simply isn't alright
it's okay say oh no you're the same
that's him that's the man who pretend to
like animal crossing to pick inviting
sipping for a girl with dyed hair
bah-bah yeah
[Music]
oh absolutely generous e disgusting
behavior and that's the problem really
oh my god that's the problem they get
off on issues they freaking love it
the problem is that this behavior has
gone on for so long we just never called
it out Romeo from Romeo and Juliet
massive set bro what's that guy a
Titanic guy whatever is a massive sim
Pro Pumbaa from Lion King massive sim
Pro it just never ends
until now because now we have a word for
it that means we can fight it
we finally have a face of enemy and I
say no more said no more we refuse to
stand by and see my fellow brothers my
bros my broski's fall into this trap
stop it no more simple you've simply
enough that is quite enough in 2016 a
swarm of 20,000 bees follow the car for
two days straight because their queen
was trapped inside god damned sips
they're part of nature now disgusting
girls and boys don't reply in two
seconds boys when girls reply in three
days simp oh you're such a simp
professional simp I knew it spongebob
classic simp you see this simple has
always been around but it end now if you
ever see a sim online post this silence
simp we silenced them one by one smash
like for this video for silence symfon
check out g feel it will cure any simply
immediately nuke up 30% off not on the
cup but on the g fuel if you enter code
peopie and that's it oh no this was not
my regular video but it's important
goddammit simple check you know what big
pee pees do they play PewDiePie's pixel
ings of course
pixal aims is a creature collecting game
I'm the primary shareholder over a
Brazilian players have downloaded and
it's got a perfect score it's safe to
say it's the most popular game of all
time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it deal with
[Music]